nightly reminder that the radicals and
the biden administration have
successfully figured out a way to turn
back time
cher must be happy but unfortunately
it's not back to 1989 when she released
that song
but 10 years earlier to that banner year
of 1979
with little hope of greatly increased
supplies and much higher prices for what
supplies there are
pressure is building again in washington
for a new look at gas rationing
there are reports that president carter
will urge congress to reconsider the
rationing plan they rejected this spring
tonight is gas rationing the answer as
has become common in many states in the
east
cars have been lining up before dawn by
the time the pumps opened
many had been waiting two and three
hours for gas
the dow dropped nearly 682
points today as well that was despite
biden officials
increasingly desperate efforts to
downplay the crisis
things will be back to normal soon and
that we're asking people not to hoard
and know that every we're all over this
folks should follow the advice of the
governors and the attorney generals
which they're asking folks not to panic
we are
working hard to maintain safety while
also providing
much needed temporary flexibility to
minimize disruptions to the american
people
no wait wait wait wait a second was that
supposed to reassure the public
it was about as believable as mayor
pete's last attempt at public persuasion
what's the biggest way that
transportation has been permanently
changed by the pandemic
we think trains plans and automobiles
but uh what about bike scooters
wheelchairs for that matter
remember you can always get on your bike
enjoy the gas disruptions be more like
pete
biden's policies are working like a
charm i think so because
when more kids finally are getting back
to school
parents are worried now about being able
to pick them up
and just when more adults are finally
returning to work
they don't know if they can make it home
on what's left in the tank
and just when businesses are starting to
reopen
they can't find employees and just when
covet is finally under control
biden's letting hundreds of thousands of
health compromised migrants into the
country
the list of biden's malfeasance goes on
and
on and on and of course the most
immediate problem for millions of
americans is this gas crisis and the
skyrocketing cost of fuel
but never fear because president biden
is on it
i think what this shows is that
i think we have to make a
greater investment in education
as it relates to being able to
train and graduate more people
proficient in cyber security
that may be true but how does that help
us right now
and even if that is true why on earth
then
are we wasting time and money on all
this indoctrination
of our kids with critical race theory
today biden could have sent a positive
signal to the markets that he's
soon ending unemployment benefits and
he's urging
the full reopening of the u.s economy
imagine if he had said that today
he could also say that he's resuming the
keystone pipeline and allowing for new
oil and gas leases on federal lands
of course he didn't but let's be very
clear
this is a classic self-created crisis of
bidens
remember covid was fixed in january the
economic crisis was fixed
all they needed to do was keep the car
on the road and instead
biden drove it right into a ditch now we
have gas shortages
they're ramping across the southeastern
u.s right up into dc and maryland
and the prices you've seen them they've
been
almost since biden won the election
going up
this is a painful and instant tax on
everything we buy not just fuel by the
way
look at what he's done since taking the
oath of office a gallon of gas is now
50 cents more expensive one of the most
arrogant and revealing statements made
in the last 36 hours
has come from that dim light bulb
herself
energy secretary jennifer granholm
you know if you drive an electric car
this would not be affecting you
clearly there's a lot of broader
questions in this
and we hope that we'll be able to see
that investment in
infrastructure that will facilitate
clean and renewable energy
that blank eating grim that was cute
and talk about tone def if you drove a
tesla you wouldn't be at the gas pump
right now
now these people aren't just incompetent
they're radical that combination is
terrible
last week after that abysmal jobs report
biden tried to tell us that the economy
remember was going in the right
direction
well now that narrative has totally been
blown up
today's inflation number shows us just
how wrong biden was
and we obviously didn't need a stimulus
package
earlier in the year now why do we know
that well if you forgot your economics
it's because you don't get inflation
when an economy
is under stimulated you get inflation
when the economy is
over stimulated which it is and to make
matters worse
joe's freebies means that well they mean
that businesses can't get people back on
the job
but thankfully states that actually care
to grow their economies are now
rejecting this damaging unemployment
benefit scheme
and if you don't want to listen to the
angle well listen to democrat economist
larry summers there is a fiscal theory
that looks at the ultimate consequences
of deficits that is flashing
a a a red a red alarm
you look at houses if you look at used
cars if you look at commodities if you
look at labor shortages
if you look at businesses reporting uh
price increases
signs are of inflation
uh starting to break out
inflation's starting to break out now if
i were larry i wouldn't expect any white
house
invites anytime soon again
these problems though really they don't
bother
the biden white house that much that's
why i ran home at that little smirk on
her face
either they're so rich that it doesn't
matter or they're hoping to benefit from
a bigger and more powerful central
government
after all their goal remember this very
important
isn't to raise your standard of living
it's to get you accustomed to living
with less
to get you to accept that america's best
days are behind us
and that we were never that great to
begin with
gas shortages are actually part of their
policy
because if they cared about small
businesses or wages going up
giving people jobs they would have
fought harder to reopen everything
early on in the cove mess instead they
fought to keep it closed
for as long as they possibly could until
the red states
essentially just shame them into
reopening for them the only potential
snag
is if this scenario starts costing them
votes then they're going to start
worrying
that's why they're intent on taking over
state elections with hr1
that's why they have to drum up racism
where it doesn't exist to try to scare
minority voters
and that's why they cling to the false
narrative about phony threats
that they're pledging of course to save
us all from do you agree with your
predecessors that white supremacist
extremists remain the most persistent
lethal threat in the homeland
i i do believe they they do at this time
[Music]
mr chairman the top domestic violent
extremist threat we face
comes from racially or ethnically
motivated violent extremists
specifically those who advocate for the
superiority
of the white race now
did the white supremacists threaten to
shut down the colonial pipeline
and are those white supremacists
committing all that crime and urban
america suburban america
it's absurd if you feel that things are
slowing down if you feel more unsafe in
your neighborhood if you feel that your
economic power is weakened
that your ability to travel is hampered
that's not
natural or a just the
way things are no none of that is normal
that's called jomentum we were told in
november that joe biden would calm
things down
well he certainly calmed the economy
down it's not moving
but i think the people are experiencing
other emotions
and that's the angle